here to respond as Texas Congressman
Tony Gonzalez he was with Elon Musk
yesterday how are you sir I'm doing
great Sean thanks for having me all
right first of all I give Elon a lot of
credit I find him I think he's a very
interesting character I think he's a
great innovator he's a brilliant mind um
he's just interesting to me the fact
that he had enough curiosity to do that
which neither Biden or our border zark
kamla Harris would do frankly says a lot
about him good for him and then told the
truth about what he saw and you're being
criticized for that yeah it's outrageous
you know this Biden border crisis can
absolutely end but it's going to take
America to demand sensible solutions
that was a large part of yesterday I
Sean I represent 2third of the Texas
Mexico border over 800 miles overall
places like Eagle Pass Del Rio El Paso
that we see in the news every single day
I've hosted 20 of these border trips
over a 100 members of Congress but Elon
was a little bit different because the
point was how do you reach the millions
of people that aren't seeing it the
unfiltered untapped real realization of
what is happening today it's Eagle Pass
tomorrow it's you the other big part was
how do you bring regular people into it
you know I'm driving in my pickup truck
elon's in elon's riding shotgun and
we're we're in Eagle Pass talking about
the Border crisis and we were I I
introduced him to people like Randy
Brown a local sheriff Anthony zer
another another Sheriff Mike Morris
another Sheriff the local mayor there
Selenas it was a real gritty
conversation and he was able to share
that to millions of people that's what
we need we need to do in order to end
this crisis you know I I find it pretty
amazing that the people that were big
Sanctuary state city supporters uh open
borders people you know as soon as as
soon as Joe who sent the majority of
illegal immigrants to New York it was
not Governor Abbott he only sent 13 % of
the number of people here uh I I find it
interesting once it hits their backyard
it's like oh oh we can't we got to
secure the Border oh all of a sudden
it's fine to be Sanctuary status or have
Sanctuary status one is not impacting
you but as soon as it you know gets to
your backyard oh all of a sudden it's
got to end and what you've been dealing
with down in Texas is you know a
thousand times worse on a daily basis
nobody see has anyone from the federal
government put up any money to help the
citizens of Texas pay the cost of all of
this they haven't and we feel very
abandoned that was the other part of
bringing Elon down to Eagle Pass not an
e not an easy place to get to and and
look Griff Jenkins has done a great job
covering it Fox does a great job of
showing those images every single day
but to bring someone outside and a
problem solver is what we need to
highlight this you know today we're
talking about New York but there is no
end in sight Sean it keeps getting worse
and worse and worse it is as if a
category 5 hurricane has hit Eagle Pass
and the federal government doesn't give
them $1 the city of Eagle Pass has
gotten nothing to date not one person
that has come over illegally has been
deported this is these are part of the
Simple Solutions we need to deport those
that do not qualify for Asylum not send
them to other places send them back to
their country of origin we have to Surge
immigration judges to the border and
that way people get their cases heard in
days not years and if you don't qualify
you leave there's these type of measures
sensible measures that can immediately
put a dent in this border crisis well it
it really is important um because every
state now is a border state that's the
realization and we better come to it
quick uh because you know food you know
shelter housing Health Care education
you know it's not like they New York is
one of the worst school systems in the
the country and they're not adding any
resources and now they got to take
teachers and they have you know 150,000
kids most of whom don't speak English uh
they don't have the capacity to and the
ability to offer anybody at that point
the quality education that every kid
deserves they've already been failing
before this latest crisis happened uh
Congressman uh thanks for doing that I'm
glad uh Elon Musk W with you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else